مساء الخير مدام حضرتك بتتابع هذه القناه
فانت مهتم بالعلاقات الدوليه وفي العلاقات
الدوليه مدرستين لتفسير سلوك الدول
المدرسه الواقعيه والمدرسه الليبراليه
وفهم منطق المدرسه ليس مهما فقط لاساتذه
وطلاب العلاقات الدوليه في الجامعات ولكنه
مهم لكل معاني بفهم ما يجري في العالم
وفهم الصراعات في الماضي والحاضر
والمستقبل المدرسه الواقعيه اوريه لزم لها
منطق واضح وبسيط جدا العالم فوضوي العالم
يشبه الغابه ببساطه لانه لا توجد سلطه
مركزيه تنظم سلوك الدول فيما بينها اذا
اراد الدوله ان تعتدي على دوله اخرى فليس
هناك سلطه يمكن ان تمنعها من ذلك
ولهذا السبب فان الدول تعيش في حاله خوف
دائم من بعضها بعضها ولا يثق بعضها
[موسيقى]
فكره توازن القوه كمبدا حاكم في علاقه
الدول بعضها ببعض
في الوقت الحالي من اهم المنظرين
الموجودين للمدرسه الواقعيه هو جونبر شيمر
شايمر استاذ في جامعه شيكاغو وستيفن في
جامعه هارفرد تتحدث اليوم عن جون مارشايمر
ليس فقط لانه منظر مهم وكبير جدا داخل
الولايات المتحده وخارجها ولكن لان افكاره
واثارت كثيرا من الجدل في الاسابيع
الاخيره وحقيقه في السنوات الاخيره
وتحديدا بدايه من 2014 لانه ببساطه يلوم
الغرب ويعتبره السبب الرئيسي لعدوان روسيا
على اوكرانيا جون مارشيمر لديه نظريه
صاغها منذ سنوات طويله قبل ان تفكر روسيا
في اي عدوان على اوكرانيا او غيرها
النظريه دي اسمها
او عدوانيه الدول الكبرى
وصاغ هذه النظريه في كتاب مهم جدا اتمنى
لو لديكم الفرصه ان تقراوا اسمه
الكتاب المهم ده في اربع افكار رئيسه
والكتاب بيحاول ان يؤصلها بامثله من يعني
200 سنه من التاريخ
الفكره الاولانيه ان في هذا العالم
الفوضوي الهدف الاسمى لاي دوله ان تكون
هجمون او قوه مهيمنه ومسيطره مسيطره على
مين مسيطره على الدول الاخرى لانه علشان
تامن على نفسك يجب ان تكون قويه يجب ان
تكون اقوى من الاخرين وبيقول نصا كده
قانون البقاء في هذا العالم الفوضوي هو
القوه القوه تضمن السلامه والقوه الفائقه
هي اعظم ضمان للسلامه ده رقم واحد الفكره
الثانيه انه
احد سلوك الدول الدائمه احد الانماط
الدائمه في سلوك الدول هو رغبتها الدائمه
في اضعاف الدول الاخرى لماذا لانها لا
تشعر بالامان ولكي تشعر بالامان لابد ان
تقوي نفسها وهي تقوي نفسها بطريقتين
الطريقه الاولى ان هي تقوي امكاناتها
الذاتيه
وتسعى لاضعاف الدول الاخرى حتى لا تصل الى
مرحله تصبح فيها مكافئه او اقوى منها
وبالتالي يشجعها ذلك على الاعتداء عليها
المبدا الثالث في هذا الكتاب انه من
النادر ان تقنع الدوله تما باوضاعها
الحاليه وبتسعى لتغييرها كلما اتيحت لها
الفرصه يعني كلما اصبح لديها فائد قوه
بتسعى لتغيير اوضاعها يعني ايه تغير
اوضاعها يعني تعيد النظر في حدودها تتوسع
في حدودها ممكن مش بالضروره تغير حدودها
بالقوه لكن ممكن ان تسعى ان تمتلك نفودا
في المجاوره يمكن ان تسعى في اعاده النظر
في المعاهدات التي تقيد حركتها في محيطها
مثال يوضح لنا هذه الفكره ببساطه روسيا
لماذا لم تعترض روسيا على انضمام دول
البلطيق الثلاثه في 2004 وهي دول ملاصقه
ومحاذيه للحدود الروسيه وكانت جزءا من
نفوذ روسيا التقليدي وكانت جزءا من
الاتحاد السوفيتي الاجابه ببساطه لان
روسيا كانت ضعيفه في 2004 وخرجه لتوها من
تجربه انهيار الاتحاد السوفيتي طب ولماذا
بدات تتحرك ضد خطط النيتو لضم جورجيا في
2008 ثم تحركت اكثر واكثر في 2014 و2022
ضد اوكرانيا الاجابه لانها اصبحت في وضع
اقوى يمكنها من اعاده النظر في اوضاعها
القائمه وقتها الامثله كثيره ويمكن ان
تشرح لنا مثلا كثيرا من تصرفات تركيا في
البحر المتوسط واتجاه اليونان واتجاه
الدول الشرق الاوسط ورغبتها في اعاده
النظر في
الاتفاقات والمعاهدات اللي ثلاث الحرب
العالميه الاولى واللي ادت الانهيار
وتقسيم الامبراطوريه العثمانيه الاجابه
ببساطه سلوك تركيا الان بيعكس فائض قوه
لتركيا لم يكن موجودا لدى تركيا بعد
انهيار الامبراطوريه
العثمانيه في الحرب العالميه
الاولى الامثله كثيره جدا المبدا الرابع
اللي بيتكلم عليه هو انه الدول الكبرى
سواء كانت الدول اقليميه او دول كبرى
عالميه دايما بتدافع عن مصالحها من خلال
مناطق نفوذ خارج حدودها يعني هذه الدول لا
تدافع على نفسها من داخل حدودها ولكن من
خارج حدودها كل دوله لديها مناطق نفوذ
وبتقول كده هذه منطقه مثل الاسد الذي
يدافع عن وجوده مش في الامطار القليله
اللي حوله في الغابه ولكن في كامل مساحه
كبيره جدا حوله هو وعشيرته هذه منطقتي لا
تقترب منها
ويعتبر ان اي اعتداء على منطقه نفوده سبب
كافي للحرب مع دول اخرى بتسعى للاعتداء
على هذه المناطق الحيويه بالنسبه له
الامثله على مناطق النفوذ كثيره جدا
وغيره المثل المفضل عندهم هو عقيده من رو
وما هي عقيده من هي العقيده المنسوبه
للرئيس الامريكي جيمس اللي في سنه
1823 تحدث عن اعتبار الامريكتين امريكا
الشماليه وامريكا الجنوبيه كل الدول
الواقعه في المنطقتين دول هي مناطق نفوذ
حيويه للولايات المتحده لا يمكن ان تسمح
للقوى الاوروبيه الاستعماريه وقتها في
القرن 19 بحريه الحركه فيها تتحرك فيها
بمعنى لا يمكن ان تسمح للدول الاوروبيه ان
تحتل ما تشاء من هذه الدول او ان تغير
الانظمه بحيث تكون انظمه مواليه وحريصه
على مصالح الدول الاوروبيه لانه زي ما قلت
لحضراتكم امريكا بتعتبر ان اي شيء بيجري
في الامريكتين يخصها بشكل مباشر
صحيح انه امريكا لم تستطع يعني ان تنفذ ما
جاء في عقيده مونرو 1823 لانها كانت قوه
ناشئه وقتها لكن الفكره كانت موجوده
عقيده كارتر في اواخر السبعينات واوائل
الثمانينات فكره بتحمل يعني مشابهه جدا
لعقيده مونرو عقيده كارتر خلاصتها ان
منطقه الخليج العربي كامله اللي بتبعد
الاف الاميال عن الولايات المتحده هي
منطقه نفوذ حيويه للولايات المتحده واي
تدخل من اي قوه اجنبيه فيها يستوجب ان
تتدخل الولايات المتحده ولو بالقوه
العسكريه للدفاع على هذه المنطقه الحيويه
من العالم ما كان يفكر فيه رئيس كارتر
وقتها ما كانش لا ايران ولا تركيا ولا ما
يحدث الان كان اللي قالق الولايات المتحده
ان الاتحاد السوفيتي ربما يفكر في الدخول
في هذه المنطقه واحتلال اجزاء منها
والسيطره على منابع النفط التي كانت تعني
الكثير جدا للولايات المتحده والحلفائها
في هذه الفتره من التاريخ نشك ركم والى
لقاء